hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so sorry i haven't
posted anything for the past couple of
days i was actually very busy
at recruiting some traders for my
project yes it's gonna be on discord
it's gonna be amazing
it's starting actually today for those
who are already on my
discord so i'm gonna tell you guys
everything you need to know but
basically we're gonna have a trading
team
with traders where we're gonna share
everything yes it's gonna be you know
some educational material
some information about the news about
the patterns about some
you know breakouts happening everything
and we're going to show you how to
monitor the trades
how to find first trades how to enter
them how to monitor
a full book you know it's not going to
be only one book so you know a portfolio
basically
and we're going to show you how we apply
different strategies and how we make
money yes because this is
what we are used to do we are
professional traders so i hope we're
going to make it but usually
you know those things when you do them
properly it's working so this
is my challenge for this year and i'm so
excited to do it with you
guys so let's see but today i want to
talk about amc
and uh let's see what the charts are
telling us so
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so uh we're here to talk
about amc and
okay what we're having here is what we
can
call i think a complex correction so let
me explain we had the breakout here
very clear very clean everybody saw it
everybody you know
here started to form i thought you guys
don't for more wait for the
you know 35 38 40 levels you know to
enter your trades
i gave you like you know my trade was by
35 by 37 stop loss 34.5
so i'm going to explain why i like to
use stop losses i know that some of you
don't like but you know
this is how i'm used to trade but first
here let me explain
what is happening so we had this
correction
abc after breakout all right so this was
last week
okay and here it was the first
information of weakness
to me you know so i'm posting once again
on my discord regular updates
about everything that is happening guys
on amc on gme
on blackberry on you know tesla football
tv
by the way there's going to be some
weekly votes so you guys are going to
decide what you want to see you know for
now i'm mostly doing what i just said
but i can do whatever you want and of
course i'm going to share with you other
trade ideas and then you're going to be
able to tell me oh we want to see this
uh
on a daily basis and you're going to
have it of course
so here i'm sharing information about
amc and what was happening in the past
week was you know
a bit tough to analyze there was a lot
of noise when you have this kind of
press action
you know that usually this is corrective
you know because uh motive waves they
are very clean
so when something is like this you know
it is correct so here for me it was the
first sign of weakness
then i had another one here all right
because
what i wanted to see is something like
this you know a one two and then we go
higher
so the first thing is that i don't like
here we go below the stream line all
right so first sign of weakness that is
starting to tell me
maybe we're not going to go to 50 right
away second sign of weakness after the
strong
rebound i think it was on last monday
here we
went too deep for me below 35 which is
too deep so here i started
to be you know kind of bullish on the
very short term of course i kept my
stance for the
medium term but it was looking to me
like this is
corrective you know like this is not the
beginning of a third
all right so then when you have
something corrective and you want to
know what it is
you guys know what to do you go to the
elliott wave book guys written by
frost and preston and you go to what is
explained about sideways correction all
right so elliot called sideways
combination of corrective patterns
double threes and triple threes
so for those who are watching my video
for some time you know that now this is
the
kind of usual correction that we're
having before you know in the 30s 40s
50s i don't know
maybe we had only zigzags and flats and
triangles maybe you know a perfect
world when after one corrective pattern
you knew you would have
a motive wave coming maybe but in the
real world
now what we having usually is this kind
of complex corrections so we need to
live with that we need to know that this
is happening
so once you have one here
sign of weakness second sign of weakness
here
i kind of felt that you know this
correction is not over and i was
repeating you guys on my discord
that we're going to go to 50 next week
so it should be this week let's see
but that's you know the right trade to
do is by 35 by 37
and stop loss 24. why
i like to use stop losses for the same
reason that here i'm start i started to
see weaknesses if we go below that
it would be one more weakness on the
path to
you know the third wave so if we trade
below that
it's telling me that the correction is
not over you know for
some time like that probably we're gonna
have something like this and that here
it would be still corrective
you know so we would need to analyze
what is happening but this is the reason
why i personally like to use stop losses
all right
because i find levels where we should
have
support if we don't have the support it
means
that the buyers are not the booze you
know are not strong enough
yet for creating this reversal so here
my level is 35 below 35 i am out of my
personal trade and i would wait for the
next bullish signal
to re-enter my position because you know
i have time to do that i'm a day trader
so this is the reason why i'm doing it
otherwise averaging down
is a very good strategy as well okay so
this is just the reason why i like to
stop losses and here you can see that we
went to 35
by the way we had this discussion on my
discord and thank you guys for creating
those discussions
uh we were discussing here this triangle
and i said that basically you cannot
start your triangle here
okay you cannot do this
because then the e-wave is you know
going higher and you know after that you
need
a leg down before the move up so it's
not working all right
this is why the triangles always start
from the top
so you have first half zigzag okay just
like we had here
you see for example you have a flat or a
zigzag
then any three and then a triangle okay
this is possible
or a flat a small zigzag so here a flat
smooth zigzag and here zigzag i think
we're having something like this guys
this is what we're having an amc
so we have zigzag zigzag and here some
kind of a flat
or maybe a zigzag so it's like maybe
three
a combination of three zigzags but
anyway if we
if you're looking for a triangle you
need to look for a triangle here
then we start from here and bam we go
higher
so we could have had this but here we
didn't hold at 37.5
we broke it and we went to the next
support level very quickly guys this is
the reason why it's good to know where
you have your support levels all right
there is no need to buy 36.5 for example
you know
there is no need because you know that
most likely you will
go to 35 so this is how i
choose my entry levels for example and
so here
now what can happen so of course my
preferred scenario
it looks to me that this complex
correction has last
long enough and that it might be over
and if it's the case we're gonna have a
strong bounce back so
this is my preferred scenario but keep
in mind that if we break 35
we'll probably go to 31 all right which
is the next support level
and if we go to 31 i mean this one two
is not
strong at all so i would be 50 50 here
if we go to 31 50 50 that
we go to 24. so for the bullish case to
stay strong we need to stay above 35
for me so let's see what today is giving
us
but if we have a strong bounce back it
looks very good
for the 50 level where we're gonna have
a question
and this is why guys i want to show you
the type of trades that i'm gonna share
with you on my discord
i have actually already shared it guys
so for those who are there
okay so i'm just gonna explain very
quickly what is happening here you know
i wanna thank you all of you that are
already there you know my kind of
early discord members that got there for
free and i want to thank you to be there
the first and to animate this place by
asking questions posting your
views your analysis you know and this is
the reason why
i give you three days where only you
guys you know so for those who are not
on my discord i'm sorry you don't have
access to this
can access all my different memberships
and i'm gonna explain
in my discord how it's working for those
who are not there yet
you're gonna need to wait until next
sunday and i'm gonna
show you guys uh how to get in okay for
now
it's uh only open to the uh discord
members
and what i shared over there already
with you guys
is this kind of option strategy okay so
let me show you
all right so on amc like i said we don't
know if we're gonna go
you know the preferred scenario is that
we go to 130 all right
next month this is my preferred scenario
but we know
that we might go to 35 sorry to 31 and
even 224
but we won't be going below 24 before
next month so basically september so
this is the reason why i have a very
nice option strategy that i share with
you
already there but i'm going to explain
it quickly here
so you take the 17th of september
maturity
you here sell the so i'm going to show
you step by step
how to build a strategy so for now your
your payoff is nothing
so you sell 10 put option
so the your payoff is now like this so
when you sell a put
you only gonna get the performance of
the stock below the strike so here below
24.
this is why we don't care because amc
won't be trading below 24
before the 17th of september so this is
the reason why selling those
of course there is a risk but it's a
very limited risk you're not losing
anything above 24. so then once you have
sold
this you can buy you know some 50 strike
calls guys
and you can see that now you have this
risky
payoff this is how it's called when you
basically sell the 24 put and buy
the 50 call but this still costs you 1
000 us dollar
and as we know that we won't probably go
above 130
before september we can here cap the
performance above 130 and make back
770 usd so now for only 400
us dollar spent you can have this
beautiful payoff
and by the way guys some of you asked me
many times
to get access to the spreadsheet so i
have already sent it
i will share everything with you guys
all my material i told you i'm going to
share some educational material
so this is one of the things that i want
to share with you so i
have already posted this spreadsheet you
can just go there and have access to it
if you are already into this code and
here
basically what you can see is all the
information
about the strategy you want to do so
here for example you can see that the
maximum
gain is 80 000 us dollars and the
maximum loss is 24 000 us dollars so you
have a very beautiful
risk reward and you can also see so the
maximum loss is only gonna happen if amc
goes to zero
which is unlikely you know almost
impossible
all right even going below 24 is to me
close to impossible
before next september of course and so
this is the reason why
i think that's sending the 24 put to buy
this gold spread
for only 400 us dollar premium is a very
nice strategy because you spend 400 us
dollars and you can make up to 80
000 guys all right so this is a very
very nice risk we will trade and one
more thing i need to tell you guys is
that of course you spend only 400 but
you can lose up to 24
right so you need to have 24 000 us
dollars on your account otherwise your
broker
will not allow you to get into this
position so
you cannot make this trade if you don't
have 24 000 us on your account
and everybody don't have this so let's
just divide by 10
it's working too okay so now you only
need two thousand us dollars on your
account two thousand four hundred
you can make up to eight thousand us
dollars and you know if nothing happens
i mean if amc stays between 24
and 15 until next september you only
lose 40 us dollars so this is the kind
of
trend that i would put right away in one
of my books
all right so this is what's gonna happen
there guys you know we're gonna
manage different books with different
strategies we're gonna work as part of a
team
as we are used to do because those guys
that have hired that guys from the
banking industry
that have experience that know how to
manage a book how to
manage risk we are used to that this was
our job
for all of us and we just want to share
this
knowledge with you guys show you how
portrait is actually working
this is the purpose of this channel this
is the reason why i started to to talk
about you know what i know
what uh what i'm doing at work and this
is the reason why now i want to grow i
want to you know hire people that have
knowledge that even i don't have
and we're gonna just you know share
everything and show you guys
what we do and hopefully we're gonna
show you how to make
money you know there's gonna be few
portfolios with different strategies
each portfolio is gonna be around ten
thousand us dollars
so this is why i want to do this it's
we're gonna do something that anyone
could do all right this is the project
that i'm starting here
with you guys so this is the kind of uh
trend that i would put right away
in my book guys but we only gonna start
it september
so let's go back to what is interesting
here amc guys so
just sum up the situation we have
weakness right we have weakness once
again below
between 37 and 35 it's you know this
orange areas that i'm putting here that
i don't like to see
this one was kind of expected so fair
enough the one that i really don't want
to see
is this one right now if i see it i'm
gonna tell you guys what it means but
it's not looking very
good it means the third wave won't
probably happen this week all right it's
gonna delay
the inevitable but it's gonna delay it
for maybe one more week
so let's see i think we're gonna hold
above 35 because i can't guarantee it
and yeah if we trade so below above
so we we want to close above 39 now this
is our short-term resistance all right
just the trend line connected between
the two recent highs
so we want to close above 39 if we close
above
39 with strong moves with volumes it's
you know looking very good for the 50
level that we need to monitor to see if
we go
higher so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys